welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham Aziz and today
I am up north I'm sat down with Sean
McCleary who is the MD of insight
recruitment and also one of the founders
of the Powell hi hi hey Jim how I am
good thank you mate how are you yeah
really good
thank you m4 so much for doing this oh
thanks so happy Britain what I like to
call it the northern version we were
yeah so basically Sean as I was saying
where I always always always like to
start is how how the hell did you enter
equipment good question and probably
quite a different route to most people
so did the whole education thing and
then while I was going through my
education I got into music fancied
myself as a bit of a DJ at the time so
was DJing promoting a club night and I
went to Abbey for a season so yeah
before I get a proper job
I'll get that out of my system so came
back from a be fair kind of decided I
need that proper job I thought right
well what can I do in the short term to
win beefer other two seasons in my
career well I went now with the viewer
DJ and I got I got a gig in like a bar
it was you know we're not talking
playing pass your ass yeah at this stage
and like you say just trying to trying
to get through the days of being
hungover and functioning you know sell
tickets or whatever on the side but no
and then came back and was like right
you know I need to get back out there
next summer what can I do in the show
I'd never had never really heard a
recruitment to be honest with you at
that stage what what can any money
quickly
what skills ever got ended up in
recruitment and Joe just got the book
from it there really and then just to
set the scene and like how long have you
been in recruitment I've been in
recruitment 18 years this year so yeah a
long time yeah I'm one of the old guys
in the office
okay cool so just a quick one because I
always like asking asking about this so
like before just very quickly like when
so you didn't know about recruitment
like how did you supply for a job or
like the devil right - really yeah I
mean I came in as I said my skills
previously been promoting club night so
it was case of right well what what can
you do and I you know looking at all
these sales jobs so you know can you
build relationships juice a plant London
yeah applied online spoke to a rhetoric
and they were like oh we'll look if you
thought about recruitment yeah exactly
and then you know got into finding more
about the job moon and actually once I
got in the office and got the bug from
exactly then and then also so then what
was the agency that you joined so
progressive yes I started my career at
progressive part of the s3 group okay
yeah
okay cool and then how long we and then
just then I understand exhaustion and
how long would you there for so I was
there for 14 years
yeah thought I'd I was a trainee when I
left I was a partner running one of
their brands I was okay and then and
then after that you then so that's right
yeah all right cool perfect so Wow I'm
sure there's a lot to cover there a nice
fourteen years then so I guess firstly
sue started as a trainee yep like what
you was you straight away in the market
you're in now or not no so I started
April 2002 it was so for those are a
little bit older it was the Lehman's
brother crash so literally the market
had just gone tits up very much I was
doing telecoms and networking which was
happened to be the biggest hit market so
got into you know an office where I'd
seen people learning silly money you
know success and it was kind of a case
of pretty much over its Alicia overnight
yeah there was the kind of the crash
happened and then off the back of that
it was weeks I mean the office we were
in went from 50 people to about 16
people over the period and you managed
to keep your job I did I did yeah they
obviously saw something in the
for them what did you get into after
that so I interestingly I did as I said
I didn't do a placement for my first six
months which I always try and tell
people when I'm interviewing them
because I think in this day and age
everyone yeah you want in that instant
success
so did telecoms for six months
as I said the market the office kind of
dwindle and then there was an
opportunity to say well a lot these
telecoms at the moment clearly there
isn't a market there what other
opportunities the office at the time it
was software development okay and yeah I
think I flourished from there the next
kind of 12 you know 12 months or would
have been the business 18 months by that
stage I went from not doing a deal for
six months to being one of the top
pillars in the business really okay
let's vote this very quickly I unpack
that a bit Lance essentially to water
firstly just if you to think back and
also if you talk about this now which I
guess is yeah is a really important
story to tell you new eyes and stuff now
what what what what how do you get
through that if you go I mean like so
six months no deal was for me I think
it's a lot free four months yeah what
made you carry on crackin on and these
things right cuz I'm sure even then back
then was the expectations quite as like
Sean like want your bill ended yeah yeah
yeah I mean I think it was you know
ultimately probably support ed around me
I got really good but I think also I was
kind of measuring the journey and I was
measuring my success my development and
trying to measure the small wins
okay so right okay well you know from
day one I've got these clients who
didn't want to speak to me my seventh or
eighth call actually I'm having good
conversations no no I am they're gonna
pick the phone up to me so it's a work
what you didn't met you medicine you to
focus on other things besides exactly
you know I think I kind of realized very
quickly that just because of the market
partly that the success had set out at
the start in terms of number of
placements and things wasn't going to
happen rather than getting T motivated I
thought you know why what am i doing
well my improve the most how can i how
can I kind of really develop myself so I
can look back over my first six months
and say you know I like India at the
time a lot a lot of my friends went down
the foot
I really you know if you think about it
you start out as saying apprentice
footballer you know you cleaning people
not sure you are these days in those
days you were cleaning people's boots
yeah you know you were looking at
measuring your fitness you were looking
at kind of developing you technique you
know you weren't thinking about getting
into the first team to kind of think
about is I kind of saw that first six
months almost as my apprenticeship to
learn mmm
and thankfully the business at the time
supported me because I think I was
showing a lot of the other kind of
attributes and I know they backed me on
that that's really interesting okay and
then I guess so then after that you went
from that being a sponge learn as much
you can these things to then like right
actually I'm in the market now that I
can actually really hit hard and do well
so how the hell did you go how did you
become a bill event yeah I think it was
Emily I am there was a market change
again I think that you know suppose
advice to other people you can't always
necessarily change your market but one
of the things I'd realized I was doing
wrong in the first six months in the
telecoms market is I was going after
every part of telecoms whereas it was a
case of when I got to move market it was
like well what is the the real niche
within a niche there's a case of look
you've got the whole of software
development to go out and I think it's a
big old place it's like well what you
know what do people want to speak to me
I have conversations about and you know
by trial and error I suppose in the
first six months I realized that there
were certain areas of telecoms that
people would want to have a conversation
with me about even if they didn't have a
job and I thought well what what is that
transferable so I really honed down the
part of the market that are for smart
yeah but the thing the other bit and it
was probably due to the experience of
not really having many jobs to work in
the first six months was when I got an
opportunity with a client I want it to
really over achieve and over the
because I thought that you know what
this is this is my opportunity now so
rather than kind of just going doing an
okay job and then thinking about moving
on to the next job which I see a lot of
people doing currently it's kind of
right well how am I really going to
maximize the opportunity they've got
it's not interesting I think I was
probably a bit of a I wouldn't say lazy
recruiter but I wanted the shortcut to
success
I saw people across the office you know
I broke down my targets for the year
which you know at the time were 250
grand Billings in a year and there was
people across the office that were maybe
dealing with 20 or 20 different clients
to get to that particular point yeah
whereas I broke it down and thought
would you know what if I can get six
clients that I can do you know 40 grand
each at the time that would have been
you know five or six placements and I am
in basement fee then that will get me to
my end billing figure that's really
interested so so not actually quite like
that because that's really I think that
I took a bit time to do that where all
of a sudden what you're saying there is
actually you're working out where you
should spend your time if you spend in
time on on X if that's building this
client relationship if it's getting more
jobs on you know that you should get you
closer to the outcome you really broke
it down because I see being hit with
Shawn you've got bill 2250 Kay yeah all
of a sudden you've gone okay well
actually if I get six light seems not it
seems a lot more achievable just do that
naturally or like did you have nothing I
think he was looking at the people
around me learning of the people that
were successful yeah
but also learning of the people that
that didn't necessarily get success and
I think also thinking about my strengths
I think I'm naturally quite a
relationship focused person hmm so
whereas I wouldn't say kind of like KPIs
and ratios and that real kind of detail
around that yeah but what what was quite
good at was measuring a relationship and
saying okay you know can I get can I add
value to this person can I get them to
buy into me can I can I really get a
tight bond that means they're going to
come back to me yeah do you know what if
I can if I can do that and focus in a
smaller area with smaller people and
smaller number of business
but just maximize that opportunity I
think a bit of a wake-up call for me was
I went on one of my first client
meetings in software development the
first placement I went went on an after
placement me in and it was with a client
Sony it was and basically I thought I've
done a great job I was you know I've
made this place that Java developer got
a good fee you know and have worked with
this one manager and I went to meet one
of the recruitment managers there and
realize that you know there was probably
99% of recruitment but I didn't even
know about that was going on in Sony you
know but I found out that at place this
one requirement there had been live
within a team within Sony for however
long so that got me thinking in a minute
what else control and different yeah
yeah that's really interesting yeah okay
I mean I definitely combats that because
I actually did a podcast of a guy called
James this week who basically said
actually one of how he's basically
because he went from like early hundred
KS Billings to 200 K it's 300 K and
pushing on yeah it kept going that way
and he when he got into an environment
where like there was really big Billy's
in there he said a lot at the time they
got it out of that to free account yep
so it's really interesting that you just
said that is that you've made this
placement like oh my god there's so much
more I can do this account but obviously
a typical recruit might be okay I made
that placement like where's the next one
okay that's cool so very quickly then
and then how long did you stay in
software development did you stand out
for a bit oh yeah the next three years
really in various capacities a--the
probably yes Reimer recruitment career I
got into kind of managing people that
was you know the standard route of yeah
you're a senior consult and now can you
stand is that something you want it
again I thought that going back to
maximizing the opportunity who kinda
came clear to me that right well I'm you
know software development is such a big
a big a big big area that actually kind
of grow a team out and probably the bit
of the control freak in me was like well
if I'm gonna build a team out I found
gonna be getting other people involved
in my clients I'd like to have some
important making sure that it's of a
similar level or a similar stun you know
I've been doing so i okay free is only
managed and then and in having the demon
is wrong so I was probably managing in
in like a team leader capacity so mixing
Billie Jean yeah for probably in total
probably five or six years from when I
started and then you know you get to the
stage where I think my last stage my
team was seven or eight yeah and it was
a case of right can i still can i still
do a good job billion and i'm probably
someone that if i know that i can't do a
really good job or winner eight then i
probably don't want to do the natural
competitive element in me was thinking
these people in my team there be in me
to start now going down the management
route
yeah and then really double down on okay
so there's quite a few key things in
there then and then we'll move on to the
next part of your career so i think i
would you agree that that's what
building manager obviously extremely
difficult right the most if that's what
i mean obviously a lot of people say
that so i guess looking back now and I'm
sure you have building managers in your
business now like what's the sort of
go-to advice or sort of the learning and
the big failures and the things that you
had to correct that help you get more
out of that building manager role with
it's two things really I think it's
thinking about what you want to be
famous for yeah okay and ultimately you
know making sure that that's replicated
in your team so that everyone's bought
into that to that vision okay so what do
you mean by that is made sure that the
people in your team have very much
approach and how they want to approach
in the same that you didn't under the
market and all these things you know
there needs to be for me like a golden
thread that runs through your team
that's like we're all gonna be famous
for this it could be I don't know for me
it was it was relationships so it was
you know we want to have the best
relationships and that could be measured
in I don't know commitment jobs or
testimonials or whatever it might be you
had something that really caught to you
that was so important to you that know
that
to the successor had there's a bill
above a bla that all of these people had
to buy on the Senate and I think the
business you know there's always an
overarching business vision but I think
if you can create that mini vision
within your tea my life is going back to
my experience in the first six months
when I didn't necessarily bill you know
I was still on a journey to do something
you're gonna think that again when you
bring in people in in recruitment
getting them on that journey early is
important if I'm the building manager
right now and it's like actually if [ __ ]
you're like my team right now I'm just
sort of measuring them how I've measured
myself and like I'm just trying to make
their me or what I did you know I mean
it's a lot what how can you start
instilling that if like you've already
hired people you know I mean yeah well I
think I think it's getting them so
firstly is getting them bought into yeah
into what the vision is that you want to
achieve
I think the second bit that I learned
the hard way is that not everybody gets
to that vision doing it the same way and
I saw when I first started as a billion
manager I was trying to recruit minimis
yeah you know this guy's this guy's
going to be like me I can see a bit of
him in it and ultimately you know again
any good team and certainly as you start
growing a business out you need you need
a diversity of thought within that team
yeah and that's another thing I learned
that okay if the objective is the same
people can get to that objective through
different means a lot as long as
everyone's bought into the end goal of
the same objective yeah so basically if
you're listening right now your building
manager you want to make sure that
everyone on your team is on the same
page and sort of really stand for the
same thing that yeah often that's
willing advice okay cool and then so
then so then basically what was there a
particular point of you saying they're
like all of a sudden your guys are
actually make probably making more money
than you need right but you saw how was
a lot how did you keep the biddings what
would you just win the accounts and
there's a lot of split fee thing I think
a lot of it was talked about having
these ongoing relationships I think you
know a lot one of the one of the
challenges for anyone building a
recruitment business and one of the
reasons I think people leave recruitment
is
I never wanted to be that person who
didn't have business coming in to me or
yeah you know did could you know didn't
have jobs within a month or didn't
didn't actually have meaningful
conversations with people so I was
always of you know let's just build a
relationship let's make sure they're
gonna come back to us let's even when
they're not recruiting how are we going
to make sure that they know we're there
if we need them whereas so you kept
making an apple one yeah and I think
whereas other people would you know
write this this client isn't recruiting
now I'm gonna go for find the next one
yeah if you always feel such a I really
like the way that you think about that
below it did my did that happen quite
naturally because like you know I mean
the typical professional recruiter is
not that it's a normal transaction was a
lot more they're just in it for their
but what you're talking about there is
actually putting the client first you're
thinking with a long-term one set do you
know I mean like that how did you come
to that like that's interesting yeah
definitely because I think I'm probably
quite a bit more medium term in terms of
my thinking of where I want to get to me
other than obviously getting into
recruitment where I just saw it as a
short term alright this is gonna be a
job to start with to tide me over once I
knew that recruitment was for me I then
thought okay well you know long term how
can I be a leader in the business it was
and and and for me that was built around
having almost kind of making yourself
redundant with but having a you know a
clear strategy of business coming in to
you that's really interesting and okay
so then when you said that you they're
not really a double down on management
what would you mean by that is it not
what did you didn't gets a lot of
director level yeah yes so probably over
so within five six years I was running
one of the best teams in in the brand at
that stage is like a team manager okay
and when you said best thing you mean
best performer yeah yeah in terms of
yield and relationships and you know one
of the things I was always really proud
of is is the retention side of things
because you know you kind of hear that
people leave managers not necessarily
leave businesses something that I'd
always try and try and make sure that
people were on the journey with me
and then from there I got the
opportunity to manage a division at the
time it was the permanent side of the
business of Chester no I was just
managing a team within permanent okay we
said right we'll look do you want to run
the whole of the permanent psycho
business in Manchester and then you know
I suppose one of the the good things
about my early time at progressive in s3
was the growth of that business meant
that ultimately they always was another
opportunity if you were good then took
over the management of the Manchester
office then over time took under
different offices under my remit I think
five different offices under my remit
well at one stage so okay yeah let's
unpack that a bit then and then we're
going to insight so laughing the first
thing that's coming to my mind is
there'll be a lot of people listen to
this office Lee there's a lot of
agencies that do I think absent the
recruitment issue in the UK employ under
10 people but there'll be a lot of
people that obviously are in this big
corporate writing class
so I guess quickly like what's come to
mind is how how did you were you said
people were you're good like you get
these opportunities like how did you
climb that ladder if you're wanting to
do that you know I mean was it just like
you always have people talking well
about you I think one of the big things
I always tried to be was be authentic
you know I think that you know and I can
only talk from experience had been in a
bigger business I think that a lot of
the people I saw who wanted to be
managers would manage in ways that
they'd seen other people manage or they
would get a message from the top down
and just kind of deliver that message
because they wanted to toe the company
line now I always told the company line
but I did it in a way to say well this
is what the company messages but this is
what I think it means to us you know and
I think I think people fall into that I
think you know I really got to know my
people on a personal level because we
have a lot of people championing you
yeah exactly and you know I think
it was now I think it might be and
resell it so one of the guys we now work
with for the power high but he remember
him saying to me early early doors and
it was in a book the 7 Habits of Highly
successful people about investing in
someone's emotional bank account so the
whole thinking was that you know if you
invest you know someone into someone's
emotional bank account in terms of when
they're having you know a difficult time
in their personal life when they're
difficult time in their work life maybe
when they you know investing when they
don't expect it when the comes are a
hard time I don't know they've had a
dropper or we're having a wobbling
recruitment or you know you've got a
delivered deliver a message that might
not be a nice message they're more
likely to respond to that because you've
already kind of you know you can take
out to look at it from a scientific way
you can take that money out because
already invested it if you're not
invested in someone and then you're
looking to take that money out you know
they're gonna be overdrawn yeah so you
taking that mindset and I'll see that
that paid dividends and treating them
like a person you know I think one of
the things I know oh come on talk about
it later but coming on to my agency you
know I was always a believer in just
really getting to understand that person
what's their strengths how can you play
to those strengths rather than that okay
let's just you know kind of blanket
money to everyone in absolute love that
and then I guess before we go into you
starting your own agency then I mean
there must there must be some obviously
big learnings through that whole journey
you know I mean because it just seemed
like the responsibility went up yeah
these things so I guess just quickly
before we move on to insight like like
what the things that you had to deal
with that you did not expect or the
things that you learnt from going from
yeah team manager director of my offices
do you not I mean well yeah yeah I think
one of the things I kind of learned
throughout my career is probably just
make sure the fundamental parts of of
your business are there and consistent
and are still invested in before you do
something else so you know one of the
wake-up calls for
was at one of the best performing
businesses in Manchester for the brand
at the time and they were like great
would give you the opportunity to go and
help grow a Leeds office and naturally I
think I was attracted by there oh this
is a new new sector new office new
people and I you know although I didn't
do it consciously I think subconsciously
I probably spent a bit more time and a
bit more of my effort went into to that
part of it and actually the business in
Manchester started underperforming and
and if you were to probably average the
performance out over the to I was
probably doing worse overall and I see
again that in a lot of you know anyone
from someone who's doing a market to be
like ok well can I do this market as
well or you know someone who's growing a
team it's like okay well you know get
good at get good and consistently good
at something to make sure that you
thought we jump on to the next thing
yeah wise man I like that so then have
you always wanted to have your own
business
do you know what I think interestingly
enough the backdrop to the whole music
thing so I so while I was at s3 for a
long period of time I was still DJ yeah
still doing you know yeah yeah I was
resident a club Sankey's which is really
my god lived with a lot of free Scouts
yeah wonderful is asked out a bit from
[Laughter]
yes I was a resident Nair for six years
kind of yeah yeah was running my own a
you know kind of it's called disco
electronica denied nice yeah yes so and
I am you know a plate kind of upgraded
the OB through experience and did end up
playing at places like Pasha space so I
had my own record label but the kind it
kind of came to the stage where I was
DJing Thursday Friday Saturday did you
have a family like another family other
misses but we're still very much living
that kind of
weekend lifestyle and again I think
that's probably something that again in
hindsight I made a decision to say right
well as much as recruitment as sorry as
much as divisions great you know
sustainable long term is that you know
and it's probably quite similar to
footballers in the fact of the only the
top 5% of the EJ's are actually going to
make a larger sum of money whereas
actually if you look at recruitment if
you're good 30% of people in recruitment
I could say can cab make awesome and
quite hard though I'm sure it was a lot
of plateaus are real passion wasn't
didn't become a passion but that must've
been quite the turning point was when I
got more involved in people because I
found that when it was when it was my
own kind of business if you like my own
desk it was okay well you know what if I
don't quite hit target or you know I
could make you up I could make sure that
during the week I still did everything
that I needed to do and all could be
successful and my buildings wouldn't
drop but I suppose if you know if if I
wasn't on my a-game on a Monday and I
was trying to build someone else's
career and developed somebody else just
was I think that that was the bit for me
was when I started to take the
management side a bit more seriously I
thought well you know what I need to
fully focus on that and you know I think
again going back to probably focusing on
something and then saw my kind of
performance as a manager wine incident
making the sort of decision actually
this sort of dgeni long term you like
actual yeah exactly so which I drop the
DJing down and saying okay you know I'd
still do the odd gig but it'd be you
know the scene the DEXA stuff exactly I
mean I'm still hanging on to it that's
right I think the most I get now is let
loose on the the office stereo know
about the yeah you know so I'd still do
more of a hobby I suppose yeah just
focused focused on my career and that
really saw me grow
and then one that led to actually I can
probably do this myself exactly and then
it was more a case of I think you know
got the opportunity from I always was
floated the opportunity from an s3 point
of view to go internationally but
because of the commitments at around the
music I always thought no that's not for
me
you know you could probably tell by the
accent I'm a Manchester lad born and
bred so you know staying in Manchester
and growing something really exciting
was always something that I had an itch
for mmm
and as my career progressed in s3 I kind
of realized that you know their
objective was to grow globally rather
than necessarily grow something
massively exciting in Manchester so so
and you know they came a time where I
thought and also I found recruitment is
evolving and I wanted to try a few
different things and it's bit harder
when you enough yeah it's more difficult
to do that in a big corporate yeah kind
of environment where they've got you
know mm stuff to think about rather than
yeah you know one person in Manchester
who wants to do things slightly
different and did you start on your own
or did you start with a business partner
yeah yeah so I started with it with a
business partner guy called Adam
Richardson we we kind of started out an
IT brand together how'd you meet at s3
would you make oh no it was interesting
he was actually a friend of my brothers
and you younger than me and gone and
achieved success in his own right with
with his own businesses he started out
in recruitment and then gone and set up
kind of call centers doing PPI things
like that financial services got some
real success and then it just time well
that I was leaving s3 he was he'd kind
of finished what he was doing and you
know it's like let's let he had an
office in Stockport on if any basis yeah
yeah I mean it's not that decent you
know I think this this you know you go
out for lunch and there was an option of
a Gregg's or a pound a pound ball issue
up now yeah exactly
oh yeah we started it together and then
grew it from there okay so very quickly
just popped in my head I wanted to ask
her so I've also had an decent yes right
absolutely right
yes free yeah yeah so what obviously
Allah sends you before he went on like I
was in my little bubble outside of
London yeah eight people know if it's
right I did not know this whole sort of
s free thing even existed there so very
quickly before I'll show you some good
stuff around that what is this s free
flies you know I mean what do you think
now being out of it and speak to
business under that what made s free so
special what made it do not I mean like
what how would you describe it um but I
think that looks similar to you you
don't probably didn't really appreciate
you the kind of the domination the s3s
intuitive probably people who then gonna
set their own business you up as well so
you're out of it and I think call Emily
you know it's the people I think one of
the things that s3 had and certainly
when I started out was you had some
really ambitious some really
inspirational people and because it was
a really kind of fast growing
environment the standards were really
high you know I think so not everybody
made it but the people who did made it
or then taught what they learned from s3
and applied that outside of s3 had the
best ground into it so it seems like
they built a sort of top class culture
and and then also actually the people
that made up that culture were like just
they're just yeah I mean I think around
the sales side of things for for what
was important at the time which was
right kind of in a lot of instances
being I think you know we were talking
about this earlier is competitive
advantage is such a big thing in
recruitment I think where s3's
competitive advantage was they just
developed sales people who would who
would be more driven than other sales
then the competition would be would work
harder than the competition or maybe
have higher standards in the competition
and at that time it was all about
probably being going over and above to
deliver
I think obviously we're kind of a
business of that size has challenges as
it grows and recruitments become more
about services is ultimately its then
also making sure that every single one
of those does it in the right way with a
customer that's where maybe I went on a
slightly different path and wanted to do
something it was a bit more boutique and
a little bit more you know I kind of
describe s3 as as in a good way the
mapped on also recruitment so it's kind
of like you know you go anywhere you go
anywhere in the world and you're gonna
get a you're gonna get a good service
from a done or you get it you can know
what you're gonna get in terms of
product it's going to be put in the
right way you might go to Amsterdam and
there you get a pint with you with you
know you get a beer whereas in
Manchester you don't get a beer but they
manage to really kind of build processes
and systems and dominate it that way
whereas I think as I've gone in to try
and do something different it's kind of
looking at the other elements if you're
not gonna have those numbers of people
to be able to be different ok so then
just to frame up so when did you start
insight so I started in sight in
February 2016 so just over and then just
very just to frame up and then ask you a
few things like see we're just you two
and how quickly and then how quickly
then is it so that right now is did you
say 30 people yeah so yeah ultimately we
I think I always had aspirations to kind
of grow some things yeah the next is
always gonna be more than you know look
I think you know I came out of it with a
clear clear path the right I want to
grow something you know going back to
being grown his team I'm going back to
my personal vision I suppose was again I
I'm quite passionate about growing
something exciting in Manchester yeah
look from an s3 point of view and some
of the stuff was London century there
was like passionate to say well why
can't we why can't we have something
really exciting in the north and whilst
they were behind that was an extent I
wanted to do that really double done
yeah so that was the first goal is you
know can I really grow can I be the best
agency in the north and you fought and
you knew that like that was like that's
what he's thinking about his issue and
Adam in Stockport behind the one pan bar
is this exactly okay so then you went
from you to then look by the end of the
what was how many people was you at in
the first year we got two so was quite
interesting I think we we did something
slightly different when we when we said
right firstly we very much focused on
the culture okay you know we spent a lot
of time on our values and our vision as
a business you know I think a lot of
people fall into that starting up my own
business and it's like right where's my
next deal coming yeah you know how can I
get some money on the board
whereas we thought you know what if
we're going to build something comes
about that golden thread that let's make
sure we everyone coming into the
business you know no you know when we
moved from Stockport for example we
moved specifically moved into um coats
because we wanted the northern Court
Manchester represented you know what we
were about which has been a little less
corporate being a bit more up-and-coming
being a bit more creative because a lot
of the recruitment businesses naturally
would be lounge spinning fields for
example okay so we've made a lot of
careful decisions around what do we want
our brands to represent and then the
other part of it was we said right well
let's do this a bit differently going
back to being really focused on
relationships
our goal was right if we can sign a
hundred clients up in in a 12-month
period rather than measuring revenue
rather than measuring how many deals
we've done if we can sign these 100
clients up knowing how I'd work
previously I knew that we would make at
least two placements per client so
rather than every everything being right
we'll where's the next deal coming from
it was like well we're
where's the next client relationship
coming from how are we going to measure
that quite early in in in that in that
process we want a couple of big clients
and it was a case of right what do we do
we say to them no mr. client I can only
deliver to you in this one area because
he's only two three four of us or do we
back ourselves and grow a bit of a team
and we made the decision to back
ourselves I think we were 12 at the end
of our first year and and then you know
we've kind of doubled in size pretty
much year on year so good I love the way
that you okay and then just quickly
because I'll ask you about about that in
particular in terms of winning clients
all these things as I said she one of
the most common things that I'm sure you
see now people struggle with and also
people ask me to ask people about his
business development yeah so I guess
just quickly to add the context and
those hundred clients were they all
without people that you aim and that
that you were in your market previously
as free and staff no no we I suppose one
of the one of the kind of benefits in
hindsight that I had was I had not been
directly recruited for eight years so
she didn't ever know yeah it's not even
that I couldn't even if I wanted to ring
someone you know I unfortunately I was
generally s3 only rolled out when
something went wrong so you know as a
client where we've had an issue or
something's happened and because the
level I was at it was okay I'll go out
and you know solve the problem situation
so I didn't necessarily have those
personal relationships so it forced me
to think about well who do you want to
make relationships with you should be
your target market how are you going to
approach those people and our strategy
was law everyone else he's going out
there trying to get them ask them for
jobs I think what can we do to just
speak to them about something else then
other than you have you got any jobs but
have you and then how can you still come
across as credible and still come across
as someone that they want to speak to so
very early we committed to doing events
okay yeah I mean well yeah so well we
did our first
then insight into we called it probably
about four months in and was the thought
process behind that just like just give
what like just do something different
yeah it was firstly when we moved into
Manchester so we moved into Manchester
about four months ago four months in and
I couldn't believe that on my doorstep
where we were in it well and whilst
there are still our and I'm coast
Northern Quarter there was a different
technique up going on pretty much every
night yeah so so it's kind of like well
that's interesting but they all had this
we don't really want recruiters there
but people and all there and and
ultimately I think that's probably
because there's a concern our our
recruit is just gonna come and sell to
us yeah yeah so I went to a lot of the
events to start with and just got
speaking to people and said look I'm not
here to sell to you I'm a recruiter by
the way but what is that relationship
yeah just tell me tell me like what why
did you find it you know I was genuinely
really interested to be like what what
are you getting out of these events why
do you come to them and a lot of it was
knowledge but kind of wanting to network
with like-minded people some people just
wanted to come for the beer and free
peace and then we said well why don't we
do something different so we did insight
into digital and it was all around the
challenges of attracting and retaining
talent within the digital marketplaces
Manchester and then we we went out to a
lot of our target customers and just say
look you might not know who we are but
this is what we would do any money not
talking some about job yeah smart yeah
and they have you run the events at s3
no we've done exhibitions and we'd
sponsored things but I think that were
actually yeah one of the challenges is
these bigger businesses is I think
everything's about return on investment
yeah yeah that was gonna be my next
things I think one may I love the fact
how you approached it approached it
obviously when we were talking earlier
about personal branding stuff is like
the best content and things like that
what you're talking about event an event
is pretty much a Content you actually
found out what these people want yeah
you know I mean so that that's obviously
the smart thing for you is actually
you're not thinking
typically a recruit okay what's in it
for me yeah for this event yeah but
you're thinking how can this be the best
value for a tech person or person
digital to attend so you buy that out
there now so my next thing well if
anyone listen that occasion well how's
that going to make me more money yeah
like what how did that then affect the
business and these things yeah well I
think if you think about it you know you
start you you know you make you know of
them any sales calls how many LinkedIn
messages emails to actually get a
decision-maker on the phone I just
taught that back to say well you know
based on the feedback had had people
were opening open to having
conversations about events or going to
you and obviously a lot of businesses in
Manchester because the are struggling to
attract talent from a tech point of view
wanted a forum to be able to promote
their businesses so is it very simple as
not allowing the gatekeeper to shut you
down because look I'm not calling about
recruitment but I'm calling about an
event that they should be a part of me
and you get through you talk to you know
kind of tip number one you're actually
getting through to someone but you know
a lot of people find challenging tip
number two it's a case of well these
people prepared to meet meet with you
because you know going back to what
you're saying it's kind of well what's
in it for them yeah that's in it for
them is building their own personal
brand yeah and promoting their business
is this so all the go in there having a
conversation you're in there for 45
minutes and now we're talking about the
event what they could speak about and by
the end of it they're like oh by the way
we need we've got a load of recruitment
that we need oh yeah okay great well we
can help you some are always been your
pulling jobs point of difference you're
standing out you're gonna be making
money from these things right 100% so
the how actually good actually good to
get your points or it's a button how
have you got better measuring the ROI so
I think going back to the original plan
was all around make you know signing up
100 clients was our first big big
objective and as I said bringing people
into the business it was all the case
all right how can you contribute to this
and that was the vision
as we probably got six months into that
vision one of the learns was okay well
we're on track to hit these hundred
clients but are all of them the type of
businesses we want to work yeah so it's
kind of that now that we make to place
without them exactly so then then you
know when you've got a bit of a
narrative and you've got a bit of a
story it's okay
refining that and to say well do you
know what we value our service do these
people value our service is there a
relationship there yeah I think the type
of business you know if we want to be
attracting the best tech people for
example he's telling them that we work
with X company gonna set us aside for
the competition well if not then you
know why are we working yeah there
represents you know they're an extension
of our brand only so that was the first
part we started to then measure you know
I suppose a hundred signed clients in
retrospect is quite a crude measure it's
a big a big picture measure but then it
was like okay well how many of those
have given us commitment jobs mmm how
many of those would meet with us and
that'd be a strap Strich kind of strike
them off straightaway if they if they
give you time meet with you then then
how are they gonna make tons will look
at [ __ ] TV so I think I think a lot
of people for me would be thinking about
how you can measure the relationship
even little things like did he return
your call yeah did the you know who will
then respond to your emails yeah I see a
lot of people kidding themselves I've
got this job whatever you are you just
work [ __ ] jobs or you work on things
that you haven't known relationship in
isn't that hard
yeah I realize I really like that okay
so a few things and so what I just
wanted to jump in quickly if you don't
mind so obviously the journey that
you've been on you've got you've
obviously now you often now employing
people
you went for I've seen big teams
managing people like just quickly and
then I've got a few other things on our
shoe what's been like like big builders
right yeah what were the things that
you'll if I'm sure you have some people
is in your business now yeah you've seen
a big bill is like what what what the
common things that were seen in these
people I think it's I think it's evolved
personally I think that some of the big
billers
s3 when I first started out they were
just you know you kind of really driven
salespeople they would push situations
who would you know would be that kind of
that person that you'd probably describe
as having the gift of the gab yeah
but they weren't always necessarily is
process driven okay and I think they
they they would but they would get
success I think in this market I think
for me it's the people that are process
driven okay thinking it's the discipline
I think recruitment it's it's about I I
see the top pillars personally they've
got a baseline standard that they never
fall below so they come in every day
they'll get the basics done and they'll
have good days where they'll you know
they'll they'll do more than the average
and the lend up being really successful
but on the days where they don't
necessarily hit those hikes they're
still still doing basic very well I
think being an expert in your market is
somewhat that I can't stress you know
highly and often you know and when you
say that are you saying like because I
think when I speak to people they're
like they're a bit worried about that
because at the end the day if I'm
recruiting into the tech market I'm not
gonna be as knowledgeable as the tech
person at the end of the end of the
phone no so when you're saying being an
expert are you saying make sure you're
very very well informed of the tech
market who's moving where what
businesses do you get why I mean
obviously to have an understanding of
what that tech person does is important
but you're never going to be an expert
what they do because that's what they
did
I see people falling into the trap of
just going back to my experience you
know software development it's okay
software development such a broad area
yeah what I won't want to do is I want
to let everyone know that I'm an expert
in software development so if they need
Java if they need dotnet if they need
this then I can supply them because what
I'm concerned is if someone looks on my
LinkedIn or someone looks at the jobs
I'm advertising if there's not something
on there that says I do all of these
areas then they might not come to me
because I think now more and more people
are coming and say right okay it's
alright that you do front-end
development well which framework do you
work with you
it's getting that leash ultimately so so
I think people fall into the trap of
just trying to keep it generic because
they worried that I don't want to rule
anyone out but actually that rules them
out but citizen but then what you're
saying is yeah redouble down on each but
and then like you should like when you
say expert it's like you know I mean
you're not gonna have as much knowledge
of the attack so you're sending it just
expert and your niche and you know
inside just just knowing who are there I
mean ultimately I'm not talking about
being an expert in terms of knowing you
know how to program or because things
sometimes people model that art but
that's why people are a bit like well
[ __ ] on I'm not as talent these
people I'm not gonna be as credible
whatever but actually it's like well no
recruiters get paid because they're
experts at knowing what's going on and
you know I mean people model that needs
to be an expert but for me you know if
someone was an expert in c-sharp then
ultimately they'd be going do that job I
think I think for me it's expectations
that do you know who the top 50
candidates are they're they're
ultimately are kind of the leaders in
that skill if it can that it speaks to
you do you know 1012
hirez that have really within that
particular area so I think okay expert
in knowing recruitment yeah so she same
process disciplined even if they have a
not-so-great day they're doing the
basics right now that a really good sort
of standard yeah being really
knowledgeable and informed of your
market
what is it anything else relationship
you know I think yeah as I said going
back to to my point I always break it
down to to my consultants you know if
200 grand is the mark that you want to
build in a year and your average fee is
10k then why go and try and do that with
20 different reverse-engineering can you
find in your market is there going to be
I don't know you do Java developers in
Manchester is there people that are
going to take on ten Java developers
this year yeah okay well identify those
businesses and have a bit more of a
medium term strategy to winning that
business than being very reactive
and just going after a business that
might have one person because if you get
five people and you do you know 40 grand
each with each of those then that's you
- yeah again it's got a lot how you
approached it yeah okay so one thing I
understand a shoe is so right now um if
um if I work inside and i'm sat down
reassuring on because i'll get this a
lot of people they sort of that maybe
150 180 Kmart maybe early 200 and they
they do want to get to the next level
yeah but typically I know you just said
relationships when you break it down
there but like typically what do you end
up talking about with your consultants
they're like sure and I just can't I
just can't get past that that next you
know I mean break for that next thing so
what sort of things are you talking to
me about yeah okay well I'm probably
looking at you you can have your kite
your customer base that's a straight
away or relations do you know what
relationships take more with them yeah I
mean you know being efficient with your
time I think yeah once you get to that
150 hundred eighty k biller you probably
feel like you're working all the hours
that you have work you know but it's
then okay well you know valuing valuing
your time are you risking every job that
you work to say right well is this
actually going to turn into a
convertible job do you know your ratios
and and now you focus in on the right
areas you know in this market for me
particularly if you do in permanent
everyone should be working in a market
where they can get multiple interviews
for their candidates yeah are you are
you recycling the stuff that you're
doing you've worked really hard to
identify that one candidate what are you
doing to get them 6 or 7 to maximize
that option rather than just getting in
one interview yeah I remember again now
advice actually it's such that is such
good advice because you I when you look
back a lot actually I'll work this job I
got to winning good people know and you
sent them to to businesses [ __ ] what
else could I do it that person yeah okay
just what are the you know what are the
things that you'd currently do in now
you can tweak to get an extra ten twenty
percent you know I'm a big believer in
marginal gains with all my business so
rather than you know try and reinvent
the wheel yeah what are the little bits
that you can get to get an extra ten
cent in each Aryan if you're doing that
across all areas yeah I really like that
yeah again so it's like okay so you want
to get to 215 you know 150 don't let
that B sound daunting away let's break
that down how many actually it's only
five extra clients that are doing ten
kovash do you know I mean okay I like
that so one or two things about actually
being a business owner there nothing now
I lead quite nicely into the power hive
and how that ended up
right so I guess surely it hasn't all
been an sunshine and rainbows oh yeah do
you know I mean so let's talk a bit
about because let this this whole thing
is not like you've been I feel like the
way you're talking about you've been
really positive and all these things
which I absolutely love but like where
has there been times where [ __ ]
nearly nearly quit the business I mean
when it's been really tough times that
you got through and looking back wow
that's really made me yeah the first
year although you know it sounds really
romantic getting to 12 people yeah all
that side of it I earn more in the
Australian less in the first year then I
probably had in the previous five years
yeah I've got about two kids that when I
staff got three three children now yeah
so so ultimately you kind of working
longer hours for less money really in
the first instance I'm sure one you had
you had stresses and actually Sean I
think it's just being clear about what
it you know why you're in it in the
first place and then when those kind of
when those times where you are you know
looking at your bank account and it's
not as healthy as it used to be you kind
of you you understanding where are you
in the journey yeah no I think I think
that be something that that I would
really say I think you know I always a
people ask me what it's like running
your own business and I kind of say the
highs are higher but the lows are so
much lower yeah that's it I think
you know you have I think it's harder to
not take stuff leaving you personally
there's a thing when you're at a big
business you know you can almost say our
role you know they didn't really buy
into the business or when you've put
your heart and soul into that's a vision
of isola you know and it's and you know
people are leaving that business it's
like okay how do you deal with that is
it just like if you know if you look at
him and go you know what I've actually
done that everything I can like that
makes you more comfort with it I love my
my kind of personal philosophy has
always been like to try and develop
people as as much as I can you know I've
been fortunate enough over the 18 years
of recruitment you know I've come into
this with as I said you know kind of
selling tickets on the side in a beat
that just to be able to go out and have
a night out to you know having a lot of
the you know the finer trappings that a
recruitment career can bring you but
I've never lost sight of the fact that
I've developed so much as a person and
you know my life has improved so much
because of the opportunities that people
gave me during that time period and I
try and look at it that way if I can if
I can bring someone in develop them as a
salesperson develop you know a lot of
these people who are coming into
recruitment are 22 23 24 you know they
haven't got the life experience they've
come out of uni you know so it's a case
of I always took it personally that if I
can leave them at a better place than
when they started
then my job is done and I think that
thankfully a lot of those people would
say we're at will do you know what the
loyalty is built there because you've
you've developed into X point that's
class where's that come from like that
you can't have always felt like that
would be always sort of you know I mean
like where's I just love the way you
like you've obviously clearly got such a
strong mindset I think I've always been
one for collaboration I've always been
one for for you know I'm a believer that
kind of like sharing and supporting each
other he's gonna come back for you I was
never one in the early days of
recruitment it was all kind of like
just be in ya know you know kind of
screw over the person opposite me
because that's going to get me a head
out I was always more of a case soft you
know what if you if you if you treat
people in the right way then ultimately
it's gonna come back that's class people
don't think that people don't think that
like P was still thinking have to be
bullish and light you know I mean no not
at all I think that puts and again I go
out to a number of customers who really
put off by that approach okay no
honestly my absolute love the way you
put that so one last question before
we're going to the power hive which I
think ties into what was talking about
they're paying forward yeah
so and what you were saying before we
went on about that sort of I said she
that a lot of agency owners that I've
spoke to light they sort of hit that
maybe the sort of glass ceiling of
lights what you said was a lot twenty
heads you know you're thirty like you
said that around that sort of twenty
mark like you found it really difficult
to push on yeah and I have had a lot of
those conversations so I guess I just
think and actually if you could share
your sort of insights and how you pushed
on through that as any yeah I think the
you know the early days of starting up
your business I mean it's probably the
same as just starting to per market is
is it's kind you're in that startup
phase so everything's pretty exciting
here you're bringing people on that's
okay you know we've got this startup I
think more and more both from a tech
point of view the clients I go and meet
but also from an agency point of view
that kind of startup idea of we can come
in we can fail we can do lots of you try
lots of different things yeah works well
I think we had a lot of people that were
of a similar mindset when we work
probably eight nine ten twelve people
and obviously I think I leader probably
got to kind of impart the way I wanted
to do things directly with a lot of
people hmm
when you get to 20 people and then
pushing on past that one of the things I
found is that you can only see you know
that gets diluted down there's only so
much that people can can you
you can't spend one-to-one time with
every single person get everyone bought
into that same vision necessarily and
it's about the systems and processes and
you know how do you measure things so
they I guess it then you're free that
process is like okay so how can
obviously it's unrealistic to have a
business full of people to all have the
complete same mindset but what are the
key things that they need to be [ __ ]
great out or hit the mark on firstly
characteristics for me really important
when I recruit people I think the two
things I always look for people that
I've got humility because I think that
you know ultimately everyone's gonna
fail at some stage everyone's got to be
able to take on advice everyone's got to
be able to kind of be bought into the
shared vision ultimately so humility is
always important for me and the people
that I look for and I think the second
thing would be have a growth mindset
because I think of this yeah and how do
you look for that people when you're
interviewing people I think it's people
they were prepared to take on board
feedback prepare to take on board you
know talking about you know maybe seeing
their career as a learning maybe seeing
okay you know I might not you know I've
taken people who haven't built built a
load of money somewhere else because the
way they've talked about it was we'll
look I you know I could have improved in
this area this is what I didn't do well
this is what yeah there wasn't one
person who's build I don't know 50 grand
in his first year or her first year and
then I've had another person who's put
me in and build underground and been
like oh the company didn't support me I
didn't get LinkedIn recruiter or I
didn't get this so I didn't get that and
on paper you thinking well once below
hundred grand once bill fifty grand
which one you're gonna go for I think if
you look at the characteristics as glass
well actually that person is approaching
in the right way
then you're gonna be able to mold that
person come down to accountability there
than that it's life your mind about a
[ __ ] LinkedIn recruiting you not so
more actually yeah I'm not doing this
I'm not doing that yeah no that's class
yeah I love that so let's go into those
you sort of round this off
laughing that when not goes into nine
feet light if someone that clearly if
you do if you if you do this for someone
like you're happy you feel like you've
done your job you're willing to share
these things a lot how did it's the
power higher yeah just in a nutshell for
those people that don't know what it is
how would you describe it the power hive
is a community I'd probably describe it
for owners and directors of recruitment
businesses I think the background to it
is when I left guess three three and a
bit years ago the first thing that I did
was go around and meet everybody that
had worked at s3 or you know that I knew
in my network and you could learn from
yeah exactly so it turned out to be 25
to 30 people so there was you know
people like dan door who's one of the
owners and founders of a moria bond you
know through to people who had smaller
businesses through you know Keith who's
now one of the partners of the power
higher go see people sort of mentor sort
of look you know again I think rather
than a source my natural style has
always been to go with the attitude of I
know less than you please tell me the
thing some people would want to go and
say oh you know I'm gray everything's
great
etc is a case of look I know nothing
about starting my own business or you
know I'll be honest with you I've got
two kids I've got a mortgage you know
back myself don't get me wrong but I'm
you know a humility one yeah exactly
exactly and people in my experience are
much more likely to want to help and so
and and and going through that process
everyone was like well you know think
about this you know go to these
suppliers for that and off the back of
it I said well look why don't we all
meet up for a lunch quarterly or
whatever just to measure how we're
getting on against each other share this
best practice share these ideas so we
had a few informal lunches and then it
was a case of do you know what like
one rookie this just between us and one
of the things was how do we get some non
excess three people in the room because
you know ultimately we were all brought
up to do things in a certain way which
you know ultimately was like well if
we're gonna actually know how to build
the best business or what the best of
the people that have done it for sure in
different ways so then we you know we
kind of we got other people in that way
and before we knew it we were 40 50
people and it was a case of right where
we want to do this regularly we want to
build it into something so then that was
really how the power hive was formed
it's quite interesting it was very much
northern based to start with so it was
called the northern power hive and part
of that was born out of probably this
kind of feeling I've got about
Manchester being not necessarily
recognizing I looked enough credit yeah
a lot of the other recruitment networks
and they're all very London centric and
they would kind of yeah we'll still come
to Manchester but it'll be a Andrew yeah
to what we're doing whereas like well
you know what there's some really
exciting businesses in Manchester let's
focus on that you know one of the ethos
is was was Northern Soul so we talked a
lot about leave your ego at the door
yeah and and and and we for the first
probably twelve months we just focused
in Manchester we got to over eighty
members in Manchester and and there was
a real demand people just saying look
there's a need for this in London
om Italy and the feedback we had that
you know you have got networks that are
quite say social well one element you've
got all the networks that are maybe more
learning for ya and we probably saw
ourselves somewhere in between yeah kind
of had the best of both of those worlds
and you know we did a first couple of
events in in London and I think we had
75 at the NED in the first one and I was
I was kind of blown away by rather than
just one idea so yeah we shoot so what's
your vision with it like just quickly
like I think for me the the vision is
that
ultimately that being part of that
network is is giving someone a
competitive advantage there is going to
allow them to be more successful you
know we're already seeing it with some
of the ideas that are being shared some
of the relationships we talk about the
driver for that business is making human
connections is we talk about it because
making human connections in the
community but also allow giving you the
tools to go and make their connections
with your customers and I think for me
you know I want to evolve it to the
stage where I can go and see a customer
or someone in the power - go and see a
customer and say yeah rampart and the
power hive and automatically that puts
them in the top 10% of these people with
something that actually can have their
business make more connections going
back to comparative advantage really
just making sure that that actually
gives them you know a head start
I suppose might love it that's classic
wicked cool mate so one or two and last
things firstly I know you just send
there but what and as we as we wrap up
mate what what are you super excited
about in your world mate what's going on
look I'm excited about insight
recruitment ultimately you know I think
we we're growing you know we're I think
we talked about it earlier we cut it
we've got a halfway through a five-year
roadmap to try and get us to a hundred
people you know I think for me still
very passionate about Crais in this you
know this hope for success in the north
but we're also looking internationally
at the moment which which again is
really exciting for me you know can
there can the man lad the monks Kali oh
go over to New York or wherever and
really replicate that so that that's
really exciting and then and then
obviously you know the power hive and I
think even just the learnings I've had
personally from you know being in the
room with some of the people that are
there and some of the experiences
they've got I think has allowed me to
not only benchmark my business and say
you know what we're actually doing quite
well but also kind of
giving me the tools to really grow it
and and also look giving me the last
part of that he's probably giving me the
forum to give back a little bit which is
something that again really exactly can
be about yeah we can make mayor
obviously loved this in class so the
last question that I always ask people
is basically if you could if if you
could communicate every single crew out
there they'd listen their take on the
advice at implement it tomorrow what
what it could be a phrase it could be a
word whatever what's bringing someone
what would you say to these people their
be listening to I think you know going
back to the humility point is don't
don't ever be afraid to ask or learn or
or you know even show that kind of
humility and that authenticity when
you're dealing with your customers you
know if you know I'm much you know admit
if you'd make made a mistake if you
don't know something don't be exactly
and just just see yourself as constantly
learning I think the other part is is
really be patient and build something
properly if you're doing you know if you
just starting out in recruitment and you
building a market don't chase the deal
because you know ultimately you've got
to build the foundations to a successful
business if you grow in a business again
don't chase the deal all the quick wins
because you know if you are truly
wanting to build a career in recruitment
look at look at it where you want to be
in five years ten years and have that in
some of the decision making processes
that you make just quickly make before
we finish like how do you instill that
in people large you know I mean like
just honestly I think I totally share
the same perspective and opinion these
things and this obviously what I spent
you guys about personal brand you've got
it's the same thing because it goes in
line with the recruitment that's right
so like how the [ __ ] do you instill that
in people when that is so it's so
difficult to see that when you're
getting rejected every single day when
no one's coming back to you know I mean
how how do you instill that in your
employees you know it's more difficult
now I found because I think that one of
the things with kind of society today's
is how quickly everything says you know
that if I wanted to go out
and you know buy something off a new
outfit off a sauce or whatever you know
I could probably and it'd be be on the
credit card I might have the money for
it it'd be with me at the night you know
so I think they're kind of that
everything needs to be right here right
now is is probably a bit more indicative
of the way people official today but I
think it I think it's going back to just
really explaining to people and being
clear with them on where you want to be
in five years time you know if you're if
you know you could be five years time
and you could be say on the same money
that a doctor he's on or that a lawyer
is on that's no joke if you know if
you're a fewer doctor or a lawyer it's
probably ten years of study to get to
them so that actual stage so it's okay
well but we could get you there in five
years but this is these are the steps
you're gonna take if you're if you're a
you know a trainee doctor you're not
going to sweat if after three months
you're not performing performing surgery
on someone whereas I think I think
that's the bit the bit really is you've
just got it I think you've also gotta
manage expectations from day one I see
more and more people as the Chinese
struggle to get talent into their own
recruitment business fall into the trap
of selling someone a dream mm-hmm so
it's you know I've got this great market
or I want to be all all things to all
people be clear on what you actually are
and what success is and then just just
be honest with people and the right
people will come and join if they don't
join then they weren't the right people
in the first place yeah and I think as
long as you've been clear from someone
from day one you've managed their
expectations then you can say to them
look yeah this is where we are on the
journey yeah and I really like that I
think again it's like if I think about
it's like okay yeah the past week has
been horrible and all these things but
yeah let's think about the bigger
picture here what kind of being these
things so yeah be not actually taking
the time to go okay well where can I be
in five we five years or five weeks
five years I like I'm sure there's a lot
of people out there that hasn't made
haven't made the time to do that jus
because it's very easy to feel like oh
my god I'm not getting anywhere but
actually as you send very early on in
your career was in six months I'm now
getting people to talk to me when they
didn't before Jimmy so my class but know
that well thank you so much your time
mayor been a pleasure